foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony em
[Music]
good morning class
today is the first day in advanced
meganomics
I like can't count they don't
know what year it is they don't know
what year Donald Trump was President
they don't know what year Joe Biden
became president they have no
clue
this should not be surprising to you
though these people
are boneheads
now I'm excited about it
I mean I know a lot of people out there
like oh this is such a disgrace to our
institution and our government and it's
only a reflection of us folks it's only
reflection of us
to be quite honest
um you know
I have been watching more and more
people on commentary about the uh toxic
spill in Ohio if you remember my very
first response is it is the people of
Ohio's fault for voting for Republicans
then that is why
that spill happened in that Republican
town that Republican District that Trump
town the Trump district and all the
while he goes up there
and not only
uh wise to those people but they love
the LIE
they love the LIE they love it that's
what they want
and and it it is going to continue
the only thing we can do to stop it is
band together in a pro-democracy
coalition
and stop these people from Gaining power
where they can grab power because that's
what they're trying to do
but it's beautiful it's beautiful
because they can't help themselves but
be total ignorant bastards
why they would put
why they would put Donald Trump out
front of their party and then when they
gained back the house why Kevin McCarthy
would sell his soul to Trump and these
trumpetites
in the Congress
it should befuddle you but it's not
rocket science
what uh what other people in their party
do they have besides these Mega morons
who else who else Rhonda santis get the
out of here I keep telling you this
and and I I know people are Gonna Keep
challenging me on it but I'm telling you
Rhonda santis is not going to beat Trump
and he knows he can't
he won't
I know the media wants it like the media
wants it so bad they want Ron DeSantis
in the race
so bad
and he might get in probably not he
might get in I don't know it depends on
if Trump chokes on a bucket of chicken
or not I don't know I can't tell
the future
as far as you know what kind of coronary
uh problems
the Cheeto dust Mobsters excuse me
Cheeto dust q and honor it's been a
while since I did that the Cheeto dust
cueing on her hands
but indictments aren't going to stop him
from being nominated it's not they won't
and they're coming
you think they're not you keep
complaining that they're not but they're
coming
Nikki Haley you think she's gonna beat
him
think about this for a second let me
give you let me give you an idea
of how Trump is securing the nomination
let me give you an idea
number one he absolutely is destroying
Ron DeSantis and Fox News at this point
destroying them
only only making way for himself to be
the outlet of information which oh
you talk about dangerous you think Fox
News is dangerous
just wait
the other way that he did it is he made
Kevin McCarthy sell his soul to him
do you remember what happened last month
well not last month today's the first of
March sorry January do you remember what
happened to January it took an entire
week in 15 votes we covered
every single minute of it here
to get Kevin McCarthy to be the speaker
and Donald Trump endorsed him all the
way
Kevin McCarthy had to have his
endorsement had to have the endorsement
of all the megalodites like Marjorie
Taylor green and others in the caucus
you you don't believe you think that
Kevin McCarthy is gonna come out for
DeSantis
out of here with that
you're not you're not paying attention
and the media is not I know the media is
like oh but there's people close around
to Santa saying he wants to run for
Brett of course he wants to run
he thought this was gonna be his year it
ain't his year
and I'm here for it
I'm here for it
you should be here for it
we are totally gonna smash up these
idiots by just letting them smash each
other up
I mean Marjorie Taylor Green's running
around talking about Civil War
National divorce
and they can't decide if they want it or
not they can't decide they have no idea
oh I don't know didn't we do that at one
point
wasn't it a Republican president who uh
who fought back against the South
seceding wasn't it I can't remember uh
I boneheads folks
I'm gonna show you a lot of Clips today
of just absolute bone-headedry and this
is the leaders of their
political movement
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
can't even form decent sentences
or questions in hearings
frankly we did the Republicans a favor
by stripping Marjorie Taylor green of
her committee assignments we did them a
favor
by making sure she couldn't look
stupid in front of a microphone
we did them a favor unfortunately I mean
at the time it felt like that was the
right thing to do that was the right
thing to do to make sure that we
censured her in committee hearings no
it's not it's not the right thing
they're dumb as dog and
everyone in this country needs to know
it and the best way to know it is for
them to sit there and say stupid dumb
bone-headed
and mock them
mock them make these people ashamed of
who is in charge of their
political movement
Paul Ryan sure as hell is
ashamed we watched the video yesterday
he's not a never Trumper he's a never
again Trumper
he know he knows what's gonna happen
he knows
Donald Trump is going to get the
nomination and he's gonna lose
not only is he gonna lose the top of the
ballot he's gonna lose the down ballot
races for him too
they're
and we should do everything we can to
make sure
that we smash them up even more and the
best way to do that is let them smash
each other I'm gonna show you videos
they Ronda santis won't even let Trump
supporters near his book
signings
won't even let Trump supporters near his
book signs I showed you a video
yesterday of Brian Kilmeade running
around a cafe on a Fox news report
trying to find someone who's who would
just
even even entertain the idea of voting
for DeSantis over Trump couldn't find
even the woman with the DeSantis
shirt on was like eh maybe
I mean I love Ron DeSantis but
there my family will threaten to
kill me if I vote for DeSantis over
Trump my family's we're all domestic
terrorists now we're all domestic Terror
that's what they said
oh it's a funny thing it's a funny thing
when these politicians put themselves in
these positions
um to um
to try to out fascist each other right
and they end up being in a situation
where
the Cheeto dust cue in honor
can say anything he wants
he could say the most bone-headed
the dumbest thing you've ever
heard in your life
and not pay a political consequence as
far as his support
I'm telling you if you're standing in a
crowd in Trump country
with 10 people
and just two of them the loudest of the
two
you know you know you know type I'm
talking about
they got Trump underwear on Trump shirts
Trump shorts Trump hats they got the
cape the the Trump flag is a cape
they got Cheeto dust around their
mouths
you know what I'm talking about
and the other eight people there like
you know what he'll probably lose
but they don't say that out loud
and they're scared of those two people
because not only are they are they
trumped up white dudes
they got two sidearms
an AR
and a fully automatic pistol
and like well yes that means I'm voting
for Trump I mean I like the Santa's
truck is going to lose but I guess I'll
vote for him folks he went to the toxic
sludge spill that he caused and they
cheered him
they cheered him
they had a huge reception for him in the
town
big signs
Chinese merch boosts everywhere
selling Trump merch from from overseas
Merck first
huge signs on houses and businesses
welcome Mr Trump
thanks thanks for the toxic spill man so
cool
and you think
and you think you think
you think
that Rhonda Santos is gonna be able to
beat Trump get the out of here
[Music]
Ron DeSantis is not that good he's just
not that good
he can't beat him he won't it's because
it's a cult
it shows with Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert with their stupid
questions and committee hearings
like literally they are trying to spread
the exact fascist propaganda
that Tucker Carlson does every single
night on his show in committee hearings
with smart people on the other side
who can take their time to just smash
this just said
it's beautiful you're gonna see Jamie
Raskin do it two or three times today
I'm gonna show those clips
this this is great folks I know
everyone's like oh my god oh it's so oh
my God this is great
I hope Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bobert keep talking into microphones and
committee hearings to be quite honest
with you Matt gatz is another one oh my
God he totally walked into
Chinese propaganda yesterday what a
bonehead
what a bonehead
it's because they're not smart
and it's because a lot of the really
really
um smart staff because I don't know if
you know this in DC and really in
governments almost anywhere meaning like
state state houses and State senates
even State Executive offices they have
professional staff like that's what they
do for a living and it doesn't matter
the they always are going to get a staff
job with a politician you're a
republican staffer you're a professional
Republican staffer you stay a
professional Republican staffer if
you're Congressman or your Senator
whatever leaves town you you can get a
job with someone else
the Smart Ones are with the people who
aren't Marjorie Taylor green Matt Getz
and Lauren bobert
the the smart staff that's left on The
Hill in the Republican Party
a lot of them have left a lot of them
fled
and it shows because they're F listen if
you think a congressman I don't care how
smart how educated if you think that
they can keep up with everything and do
everything you're you're boneheaded
they rely on their staff in Washington
DC to do their work their staff is very
important to get their jobs done
and it shows that the Republicans do not
have
do not have Smart staff anymore at least
the leaders of the party Kevin McCarthy
Matt gants Lauren bobert Marjorie Taylor
green Paul gozar these are the leaders
of their party Andy Biggs that
fascist in Florida Ron DeSantis they're
not smart folks they're not smart
and they're only out for themselves they
are not in this job they are not in the
service for the public
and it is showing more and more and more
the more they talk the more they
do this
and we should be cheering it on
they're going to destroy themselves
because they absolutely are
delusional and they are in the biggest
Echo chamber you could ever be
in and it is loud as in that Echo
chamber we show it here every day we
show it to you every single day Marjorie
Taylor green
is questioning a witness about fentanyl
a mother whose sons died in 2020.
and Marjorie Taylor green blames those
deaths on Joe Biden because he's the
president now
she also tells you how bad the Trump
Administration was at stopping Fentanyl
at the border and she thinks that's a
bad thing for Joe Biden folks I'm
telling you
politics in this politicizing things
there is no better gift than these
meganomics that they got going
on
and God bless whoever came up with
meganomics the God that I don't believe
in but God bless that person who came up
with the phrase meganomics I don't know
who it was
but these meganomics are going to save
our political situation
save us
from this scourge of fascism
that 12 percent of the population is
agreeing with
the loudest 12 percent there's there's
millions of them that's scary
and it's highly concentrated in certain
areas like East Palestine Ohio heavily
concentrated dumb up there
heavily concentrated
some states it's more concentrated than
others
foreign
but it's up to us we will get through
this and the reason why is because we
have to engage in our democracy we have
to let everyone know
we have to let everyone know
the bone-headedry
that these Party leaders of the America
First Nazi party
have
and what it will do to our country
people will believe you I'm telling you
there was supposed to be a big red wave
the only reason why they won the house
is because they gerrymandered the
out of districts and we should fight
back against that
as important as this next race is
because that's the one we're talking
about it is important that we keep the
momentum to 2028 how do you think we're
going to change the sentence census
in 2030
we have to keep this momentum pushing
pushing and pushing on them
because we have to gerrymander districts
I hate the I hate to break it I hate to
break it to you you Pearl
collection liberals
but we have we're gonna have to
gerrymander districts in blue States
you're gonna have to do it
your efforts to try to get states to
voluntarily and try to get Republicans
to voluntary on gerrymander stuff is
just not going to work it ain't gonna
work they're boxes they're
garbage
so what do you do you convince them that
we'll do it and the oh buddy will they
start will they start to make sure that
you can't gerrymander districts they'll
take that they'll take those
rights away from you quick they
love to take rights away from
don't they
oh they love that they love to
take some rights away from some
yeah
that's that's their
you start gerrymandering districts
they're gonna whoa whoa whoa wait a
second
are you telling me the Democrats are
actually going to start trying to trying
to make sure they rig up these districts
so they have majorities you goddamn
right we are
you know what they'll do they'll move to
undo that
and we should be there waiting to help
them
how do you think it works
you think you're gonna nicely convince
these people to not cheat
is that what you think
if you're standing there like oh
eventually we'll convince the fascist
that uh that democracy is uh is the
thing we should do okay
good luck
you have to my you at you have to play
Reverse Psychology with these people I'm
telling you I'm telling you
wait until you watch this tape from
Marjorie Taylor green thinking that it's
Joe Biden's fault that two people died
in 2020 and then the reason that she
gives is that more fentanyl is being
stopped at the border under this present
than the last one
they're catching more Fentanyl
they're catching more
because they're doing their job because
you know
that's what serious people do in
government is do their job not
pretend to do it
not to have fake stacks of paper uh
infrastructure week that that is
just impotent every week they actually
do the job
and that's what I keep telling you the
two things in government
there's two things
there's the policy where you where we
elect serious policy makers to legislate
and to set policy and to administrate
policy
and to check it with the judicial branch
and then there's elections that's the
dirty part oh that's the nasty part
that's the part that I'm involved in
that's the narrative that's the
messaging part that's the part that the
right has done so well for the last 40
years and the reason why we suffer under
these magnomics
because bonehead's gonna bonehead
and for so long
the the media and and what is the
establishment liberal media
has proven that they think they're Elite
and they're smarter and more
intellectual than you
and you just can't understand liberalism
and freedom the way that they can
that you don't need a bunch of
polls you don't need a bunch of data I
don't need to be talked down to to
understand what democracy is what
democracy can do
it doesn't take a degree in rocket
science to understand that Liberty will
deliver you equity and equality and
leave alone mind your own
business people you don't need a
big college degree or a doctorate or go
to an IB School
or have a sweater that has a school name
on it
you don't need to have a big syndicated
show or some article where you're where
you're a writer in the New York Times
are a big education or use big words and
make sure you give evidence oh there's a
New York Times article that reported
that
you think people in this country are
reading the New York Times get off your
high horse they are not reading
that
people let me tell you something and
it's not just it's not just Trump
supporters people are sick and tired of
being talked down to
they're tired of it
it's not hard to understand that you
shouldn't go broke because of a
medical bill it is not difficult to
understand in this country that you
should have a living wage that
you can afford to raise a family on and
not be flat broke and not be
able to retire when you get to that age
it's not hard to understand that parents
look they can't afford they can't afford
daycare it's much easier when the kids
start school at three instead of five ah
oh who'd have thought that and it helps
their education makes your little
smarter
it's not hard to understand that
Americans don't want hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of debt to be
deemed successful in this country by way
of a college degree it's not hard to
understand this
I don't need your polls I don't
need your data I don't need you
to tell me what New York Times or the
Washington Post wrote I don't need it
and that is why you come here
because I don't do that and I ain't
gonna do that
Arguments for Liberty and freedom
equality and Equity are really
easy oh my God they're super
easy
they're simple
they're very concise
you don't need a lot of brain power to
see a bunch of bigotry you just
don't
you just gotta point it out
and shame those I know
they don't have much shame I understand
it's very difficult trust me
we do it every day here and
they just don't ever get it
but people like Marjorie Taylor green
and Lauren bobert Martin Kevin McCarthy
Donald Trump oh my God we're gonna I I
don't read a lot of his statements but
we're going to read some today because
he is losing his mind
whew
the Cheeto desk you and honor the cheese
has slid off he's cracker and I am here
for it
and Ronda santis can't figure out if
he's a trump supporter or not he has no
idea
no idea
they're people
and the only way is if you engage that's
it that's it
if you engage
I only have one microphone just one you
are thousands of microphones thousands
so I'll give you the ammunition I'll
give you the the Canon fodder that you
can go out and use
it's not difficult though the arguments
are very simple
they're very simple they're it's a very
easy narrative it's not hard to drive
you just can't let these
Bourgeois liberals stand in your way
we can't let them they're trying hard oh
my God are they trying who's gonna run
against Joe Biden he's too old he's too
old you're a dumb there
ain't a person in this goddamn country
in their right mind that would go up
against a record that Jill Biden has you
are a dumb son of a if you think
if you think for a second there is a
Democrat that can challenge the record
of Joe Biden you you are not paying
attention well he's old though Tony he's
old he's old
he'd been in government way too long why
do you think he got done
you think he got none not knowing
what the government how government works
foreign
yeah okay okay good good luck good luck
with anyone running against him I wish
you the best of luck just what like I
wish Ronda Santos the best of luck of
running against Trump
out of here
it is going to be Trump and Biden in
2024 get used to it get saddled in that
that is what you should expect
they're telling you that's what to
expect
and by they I mean the the actual party
not the idiots on the TV the
idiots on the TV are just trying to get
a segment
that last 30 minutes when they don't
know there's plenty of to talk
about that could last 30 minutes that
people give a about
people don't want their rights
take I don't know I we spent a lot of
time yesterday about the uh the the
anti-trans bill in Tennessee
we spent a bit of time yesterday about
how these America First Nazis
want to uh uh genocide of the lgbtq
community
we spent a little bit of time on that
yesterday I think that's very important
if you're cons if you're concerned
about domestic terrorism and if you're
concerned about your countrymen
what is there to fight for if there's no
if there's no people left in this
country huh what is there to fight for
because if we won't fight for them who's
gonna fight for us
huh
think about it
it's very important very important stuff
that's why you come here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours
every single weekday oh boy do we got a
lot of tape to show you today they're
just non-stop
they're just non-stop with the
oh my God Marjorie tether green and her
math and her numbers what the
I couldn't help it I wanted a different
thumbnail I wanted a different title
today I really wanted something
different but I couldn't I couldn't
ignore
the advanced magnomics of Marjorie
Taylor green I just couldn't do it I had
to make it it she forced my hand
and I'm happy about it I'm happy
about it today on this truth everyone
the shitlist Roundup is coming up right
after this hey during the break if
you're gonna leave don't leave by the
way but um
go check out the patreon page
patreon.com Tony Michaels we're at 125.
we're so close so close to the goal of
150. thank you so much to all the
supporters out there on patreon and also
if if you can't do the monetary sport no
problem the best support is to hit the
like button and share this broadcast
that way we have more people in the chat
when we come back right after this break
what the is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
[Music]
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
comfy
you guys think you want to shoot this
for a minute
this
throw some questions in the chat
I'll answer your questions here and I'll
tell you what the is
I'll tell you what the is while
we're doing that I do want to thank
again all the new members of the patreon
that is this is my job and that is how I
make a living so I appreciate you guys
uh throwing Support over there but I
also want to show you how you can
support the show while we wait on a few
questions to hit the chat for shoot the
um if you're on YouTube right now
subscribe it's free it's free
doesn't cost you a goddamn thing to
subscribe and hit the like button or the
thumbs down I don't give a if you
don't like it then thumbs down
too I don't care and share it if you
don't like it share with all your troll
friends get them in here too yeah that's
right I want them watching too why not I
want eyeballs on this go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels POD at the Tony
Michaels and I am Gabe Sanchez Gabe's
going to be joining us uh here in a
minute I believe for the list and
download every single episode that is a
great way to support the show I don't
know if you know this
but the audio version is uploaded every
single day in the afternoon after the
show is done airing I have to edit it a
bit
for the audio version but once I get it
edited and uploaded you're able to
download on your favorite directory and
it helps out if you download every
single episode listen to the first 30
minutes that the a block is always the
the
that's where I go hard right every
single day 30 minutes the first 30
minutes of the show
sometimes I don't even know really what
I'm gonna say before I get on I don't
I know what the title I know what the
day I know what the stories are I know
what we're gonna kind of show in the
rest of the show so I kind of want to
preview that show you what we're going
to have but
go listen to the first 30 minutes you
can listen to it like twice as fast even
though it'll be really fast
I'm just kidding I'll be speaking really
fast in it but you know go listen to the
first 30 minutes on your favorite
directory also follow us on Facebook if
you still have a Facebook page if you
haven't been kicked off or banned over
there yet
uh at the Tony Michaels at the Tony
Michaels and then follow us on Twitch
here is a very free way
to give us cash well sort of not like
dollar bills but money
here's a free weight
you can log in to your Twitch account
with your Amazon Prime account if you
have an Amazon Prime account you can log
into your Twitch account with it
and you get one free subscription you
can actually give that subscription to
us the Tony Michaels podcast
and we get a few bucks it literally is
like two three dollars I'm not kidding
you but it's Jeff Bezos money right so
like Jeff Bezos we get to pick his
pocket if you got an Amazon Prime
account and you can let me have a few
dollars of Jeff's money I'm just saying
it's a thing that exists see you should
do that you should support the show that
way if you can if you have an Amazon
Prime account
shoot the let's see what do we got
to be any questions
do we get any questions here
uh someone's saying sing you want me to
sing what what am I singing uh any
questions in the chat we're shooting the
you got the opportunity to ask me a
question
um
let's see what are we on
do you guys have any questions is it is
it a slow day out there
I don't know
it must be a slow
um oh here we go and here's one Melody
uh Tony yes will the obvi obvious
pending indictment stop Donnie from
running no
no sure won't it'll actually help him
I I know the conventional wisdom is he's
going to be indicted and that's when Ron
DeSantis is gonna swoop in
no wait no I won't no it's not gonna
stop that's why he's running you gotta
remember why he's running he's not
running to stop indictments I mean
that's what he's going to be yelling and
screaming right
but he's not running to stop indictments
he's running to stop a trial
indictments don't mean a hell of beans
worth of if you don't ever go to
trial
right if they don't try you they can't
put you in jail
so his goal is to convince a federal
judge which it will work if this is
gonna work
I'm telling you this is gonna work
you know it I don't like it I actually
don't like it I think if you're
federally indicted you shouldn't be able
to run for office and you shouldn't be
able to hold a federal office I truly
believe that
uh we had Bob Menendez a Democratic
senator from New Jersey he stayed and
remained a senator while he was under
Federal indictment he went to federal
trial I do not think that should be a
thing
but a federal judge is going to stop
Donald Trump's trial
because here's what's going to happen
this is his this is the whole purpose of
him running is he's going to win
primaries
it's he's going to have by by some time
because you got to remember we're
probably going to see indictments
sometime this spring right
which which means that he's going to
Kick the Can
into next year which next year he'll
already have won several primaries
and because he's won several primaries
and he'll probably hold
more delegates than the other republican
nominees Nikki Haley and whoever else
I mean he's definitely gonna hold more
than Nikki Haley he's going to be able
to they're going to be able to file
motion with the federal judge
and say look he's running for president
you can't take him to trial they're
going to Grant him that wish
that that that is what is going to
happen
expect Donald Trump to be indicted but
not not sit in trial until after the
2024 election it may be long after it
may be well into 2025 possibly 2026.
before his case would ever go to trial
understand that and understand that is
the goal of his campaign
is to avoid going to prison and the way
he does that is to avoid a trial they
can't send them to prison without a
trial that's not a thing it's
it's not a thing
so just be aware of that the reality
that's why I keep telling everyone
Rhonda santis will not beat Donald Trump
they're not
um
Christina says here and we're going to
watch a clip of Ted Cruz Christina this
isn't a question
um but she says that she's pissed off
about the angortainment which theater
which Ted Cruz they're just yelling at
uh attorney general mayor Garland
and in the Senate Judiciary Committee
hearing today
they're being rude and disrespectful
that's not a glitch Christina that is a
feature of these boneheads uh
let's see
uh Robin points out a question here
what's your opinion on the woman uh that
says she's running against Biden uh are
you talking about Williamson Marion
there's not anyone that listen
Sandra
Sandra there is no one who will be able
to beat in these primaries Joe Biden's
record they just will not be able to
beat him just like there's no Republican
that will stand against Donald Trump and
his cult
they just won't
it's not going to happen I I know it
feels good to think that someone might
beat Donald Trump in the primary
but I'm just giving you the real
truth here and what I think is gonna
happen and you don't like it well I mean
that's fine you can have your opinion
too
any snow in my area no
no snow in my ear it's actually been
pretty nice here
I know a lot of people been getting snow
right this is suddenly off but yeah
[Laughter]
oh let's see
[Music]
um
yeah
I see
do I think covid started in a lab
from Facebook
oh this is definitely going to get this
episode banned
listen here's the problem with the
premise of covid starting in a lab is we
don't have good enough evidence we
talked about this yesterday with Texas
Paul we just don't have the evidence to
prove this and China is never going to
give us the evidence if we may get it
one day decades and decades down the
line
but the fact of the matter is is that it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter covet is still coveted
still killed millions of people
it still did what it did and we did not
properly fight against it in this
country because Republicans stood in the
way of the public interest
which I don't know not die
and now they use Fox propaganda as the
tool
to sow even more doubt
they're like oh even mask don't work you
people are dumb as dog saying that
mass oh there's a study well there's a
study well there's probably a study out
there that shows me why I should eat my
own but that ain't a good study
okay it just ain't
the reason why we use Mass to fend off
viruses is the same reason why we've
been using mass to fend off viruses for
I don't know
over a hundred years
it's the reason why doctors and dentists
and anyone that's close to your face or
doing surgery on your open body wears
one it's not complicated to understand
it really isn't and to actually say into
a microphone but masks don't work
to protect against viruses
what what was it a hundred percent no no
one no one no one thought that mask were
going to protect you 100 Jesus Christ do
you remember the point in the pandemic
when they were telling you where to mask
because they're like look one mask is
not preventing as much transmission as
we need we need people to wear two masks
it's all bone-headed so do I think
that covet started in the lab what what
what the does it matter
whether it started in a lab or not what
the does it matter if it started in
Wuhan or bum wherever
it doesn't matter it happened it exists
and we have to continue to do something
about it
because people are gonna get sick from
it from now on that's just that's how
it's gonna be
and right now to act like the
vaccine isn't working because you're
like oh well you got to get a booster
yeah how good is a cure no one said it
was a cure number one
and they never even claimed that it was
100 effective
against never getting the virus ever
ever in the history of ever from now on
no one ever said that from the moment
the vaccine was released they never said
that
matter of fact you when they released
the vaccine if you recall you were gonna
have to get two shots initially
which only indicated that you were gonna
have to build immunity through more more
vaccines this isn't again it isn't
rocket science they're just taking these
little crumbs of facts and making up all
kinds of crazy nonsense about how well
don't even plan on anything
so do do I
um do I believe that it started in the
lab I have no idea I don't have any
evidence
I mean the department of energy said
they have low confidence that it
actually happened that way so I guess my
confidence is low with their confidence
is low I don't know
I don't know how much I even trust the
department of energy to do a study based
on no evidence that China gave them
that's probably why they have low
competence I hope that answers that
question okay let's say
we can't even um
[Music]
again another question remember we're
shooting the so if you got a
question throw it in the chat
exactly if masks don't work why do these
surgeons wear them or the dentist have
you ever been to the dentist where
they're right in your face you want that
you want that person not to have a
mask on is that what you want I
mean if you're down for that whatever
you know go ahead good good luck good
luck
oh son of a
how can we save Florida someone asked on
Twitch how can we save Florida just keep
pounding at the at the microphone that's
all you gotta do is keep going
keep going I I know I know it feels like
Florida is lost but it's the people
there that are lost not the state
again the same way as in Ohio
if there's if if you're complaining in
Florida about your student can't
learn where the my son's in fourth
grade and he doesn't even know how to
read well that's because you live in
Florida and you vote for republicans and
you vote for fascists that's why your
kid can't read
and that's how you should say it
again it once once the narrative
switches in this country these people
will go crawl back underneath their
rocks
it's not complicated to understand this
stuff
um so I hope that helps
probably probably not especially if
you're living in Florida well let's see
um
uh Cindy um says and Cindy's pointing
out here if it was released from a lab
which which is a good point but again
there's the problem is is we lack the
actual evidence to to say yes or no is
it a possibility anything's a
possibility because we don't
know so like you could just pull any
rabbit out of any hat here right and
anything's a possibility with covid and
any any origin is is a possibility
because we don't have the correct
evidence to prove or disprove which is
the important part to to say no that's
not a possibility
but Cindy says if the former guy hadn't
dismantled the Obama placed observers in
China the pandemic may have been avoided
or did anyone else forget that little
detail
again that's one reason why we can't say
we can't say for sure is because some of
the the actual observers because I don't
know if you know this in the Chinese wet
markets where they originally thought
this or this originated
and it's still a possibility they had
people would go test these birds
and test these other animals in these
wet markets continually test them to
make sure viruses weren't
spreading like wildfire
paid by our tax dollars
for this very reason to know that if
some virus breaks out it's going to
spread all around the world
affecting our citizenry which is it we
have high stakes in like millions of
people dying during a pandemic I don't
know if you were around and you remember
what happened I don't know it was a
couple years ago this thing called
Corona virus covid-19 I don't know if
you remember that or not but it's in our
best interest so yes Cindy I mean
obviously that is one reason why we
don't have the correct evidence is
because the observers on the ground were
not there as in as plenty as they were
before Oh someone's joining us here who
is this who is this
let me see who is this guy who is this
gang oh Gabe Sanchez welcome to the show
did you have trouble with your camera
you came in and out
uh
yeah I I figured maybe I thought you
were switching yeah it was yes it was
because uh and it wasn't Monday it was
Monday you had problems yeah no no I it
was um my Wi-Fi I had connected on Wi-Fi
but because I'm going through like a
couple rooms yeah I forgot to disable
the Wi-Fi so then I jumped out wow icy
I'm a hard hard you're hard in yeah hard
wired in okay ran it through the line
ran it through the line but the other I
I will add one thing um you heard the uh
Wuhan lab yeah because it's been out for
a couple days right but I think what
everyone needs to realize too is this is
a very low confidence Theory right like
that's the actual quote from yeah
they're like this is a theory that is
possible but we don't have very high
right I mean like yeah
I get that you have to report on
everything but the fact that you're like
uh like it
uh like I
um I don't know if it's that thing also
like the energy depart like the
department of energy it's funny to see
Republicans be like oh yeah Department
of energy oh man oh man oh man they're
so dude I they're so really I always I
always trust the department of energy
which is so I don't know kind of ironic
the the group of people that are so very
much like a green energy
yeah I'm gonna waste as much
energy as I want gasoline this oh
this oh well whatever and then they're
like oh yeah but the department of
energy when it comes to their uh
intelligence kind of analysis
I with that all day I trust
them until the end of time they are the
OG right I don't I don't go with the CIA
or the FBI but the department of energy
if you believe that report if you
actually believe that report then you
wouldn't be you wouldn't have very good
confidence that it started in a Wuhan
lab right if you believe the report if
you actually believe the report but
that's what they don't right you but
everyone everyone that's like
regurgitating the oh well you know it
came out of a lab they're not following
the next sentence that comes through and
says this is based on a low confidence
you know reporting like it's we we we're
giving you some insight in what it could
be but then again it could come out of
it like it could have developed from
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
that's a theory right like somebody
could be like oh you know what I mean
that is a theory right you're like oh
yeah we have no evidence of so you would
have low confidence that that would be
the possibility someone could be like oh
it was because Tony Stark snapped his
fingers to reverse Thanos and because of
that covid came out right I could make
that argument and I could say that's
what our very low confidence but I could
still make that argument well I love how
they jump from that to mass don't work
like on Fox News like that that was
Jesse Waters every one of them really
they like jumped straight from there is
low confidence we we have not much
confidence at all that this started in
Wuhan lab they jump from that to mass
don't work and it was like wow you
really you did a whole yeah I mean they
they jump you know like covid you know
potentially jumped from like animal
species to humans right they jump from
Wuhan lab to mask stonework but keep in
mind people at Fox News all got the
vaccine okay of course they did yeah and
they all wore masks before they got on
camera yeah exactly and yeah the
people doing makeup and hair and stuff
they wore masks they had to wear masks
who were the people that were in the
chair there is no way that they did not
have a protocol in place
still might have mask on which I would
wear a mask around these people oh yeah
have you ever have you ever seen Greg
Gutfeld spit his out of his
mouth I would much rather smell
like here regardless of where you sit on
covid you know and whether it's real or
not real or you know it's exaggerated or
whatever masks have many benefits one
you can cover your mouth so people can't
smell your bad breath two you can cover
your face let's say you have a blemish
or something on your face like a a
pimple or a scar and you want to cover
it up you know the other thing too is
like you just don't want to talk to
people mask on I saw someone in the
grocery store the other day and I I you
know I was like oh because I knew them
but did you throw the mask on no I had I
had the mask on but it was one of those
moments we caught eyes and I was like uh
uh and it was that moment like I have to
say hello here but in other situations
you could easily like sorry can't talk
mask on you know like like just like
didn't even see you the mask provides
many benefits and I'm surprised I am so
surprised that Republicans for their bad
breath fugly faces and their
inability to or rather lack thereof to
be social you can use the mask for many
things many many many many years masks
have been around way before that I went
to I've been to
Japan before years ago there's cult
there's cultures societies because they
have a there's a thing if they're
they're tick you wear a mask right there
is the the the courtesy the selflessness
to say like oh you know what I'm sick so
I'm not gonna go to people sick but it's
just part of that it's kind of a warning
too right like like hey I'm I'm not
feeling well right but again you could
also say for like oh you know I've got
something on my face and I don't want
people to know right my daughter had the
flu a couple weeks ago
and uh she she developed a a croup kind
of because of it right and um so for
like three or four days she wore her
mask to school we didn't we weren't like
you have to wear your mask but she wore
her mask to school because she didn't
want she didn't want to cough on anyone
else accidentally because she's not an
so right and it's it is amazing
to see younger children
take that on because obviously you know
like but I mean they they but that's the
thing is we weren't taught that no
did you ever wear masks no I mean like
as a kid I never I never learned to wear
a mask and like growing up in the
midwest it was always like you
dealt with it right I can't believe I
can't believe when we were kids we would
go because I lived in a really
small town and we had like one or two
doctor's office in this small town and
they their waiting rooms were like the
size of a closet yeah and everyone would
be sitting around coughing and hacking
and no one ever thought you know what we
put mask on I won't get what you got and
you won't get what I got how we didn't
I mean it's just one of those
things where it's like even if you you
know you don't believe covet or whatever
like a mask does have benefits to either
again hide your face or you're like look
I
am sick and I don't want to get you sick
right it's not just like covet isn't
like a one-time this is the only way
that a virus can spread kind of thing
like that's how all sicknesses work
right if you if you stop the
transmission
from your mouth or your nose or whatever
then you can prevent the spread right
and I would hope that other people
if they've got older or
immunocompromised people or people that
they care about and they want to
have in their life no matter how racist
or bigoted they are and so they could
spread those lies with them I would hope
that they would want to have those
people around a little bit longer as
opposed to oh man he died but he
owned those Libs you know well I
mean here's the thing though here's the
thing though is that the mask I mean
talking about the mask it's not just
about covid-19 it's right like like I
said my daughter she had a croup and and
you know she would cough and and she she
when they were a kid they said cover
your mouth your hands which is totally
stupid too yeah so they do the oh she
does the elbow right but she has a mask
on so if she can't get her elbow up
quick enough she's at least not spewing
right on a river but here's the
thing one thing I learned about myself
in this whole masking thing during the
minute because I didn't wear a mask much
and here's what I mean by that because I
didn't go out much yeah the only time I
mean I didn't have to wear a mask at the
house
so well I I didn't have a mask on the
majority of the day and I wouldn't I
wasn't sleeping in one right so I mean
if I didn't want to wear a mask I just
didn't go nowhere right but here's one
thing I did discover about myself
I had no idea what my brush felt like I
had no idea I had no clue I did not know
that is what it smelled like it smells
beautiful by the way I mean it smells
like honey and Roses oh okay but I had
no idea yeah I think you get a bit of a
wake-up call you know if you're
breathing in your your same breath all
the time you know and you're like oh man
I gotta change up the dental routine
here baby I bet Altoids made a ton of
money during the pandemic what do you
think yeah Altoids or gum or something
like that you know like
yeah who knows maybe a looting you know
whatever right
um Mason has a question here to uh wrap
up the shoot the um segment here
before we go to the let's round up
because I got a ton of video I gotta
show you Gabe oh my god oh yeah I'm sure
you talk about the party is stupid today
it is stupid and stupider
um says amazing says Tony uh do you
think meatball I'm assuming I'm assuming
you're referring to the Santas because
that is his official name now meatball
wants to see Trump behind cars more than
any other American in order to get him
out of the way I mean really honestly
um Trump's not going to be arrested by
the time we get to the presidential
election so Ron can count that out
um but meatball meatball would really
love that because again he's a snake in
the grass waiting to pounce right
and a bucket of chicken or behind bars
or getting a cheeseburger lodged either
way any of those options
those are really good options for Ron
DeSantis to start his presidential bid
here but you know speaking of that we
got to go to the shitless Toronto
because I got to show you
a a video put out by Laura Loomer oh my
God yes it is great this is one of the
most fantastic videos you're gonna see
this week so we're gonna we're gonna go
to the let's round up we round up
all the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends
start the countdown
[Music]
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
the list
welcome welcome back to the show you
reached one of the show we round up all
the Tweet tweets of Journey Trenton I
promised you a great video from Laura
Loomer you know Lauren Loomer is oh yeah
the loser
loser
[Music]
she's a psycho I mean yeah 100 I mean
here's things she's a psycho but she's
also part of the anti-uh
she's
anti-milianopolis anti-margie Taylor
green right you know she was the one who
was pulling out or you know not she
hates meatballs by the way she hates
hates hates me yeah yeah yeah and that's
the video that I'm going to show you
here
um that gay guy Candle Company tweeted
this video and said DeSantis is now
having a police called on Trump oh yeah
I did see this yesterday yeah yeah this
video what does that store books a
million this say this this video is you
can see it's originated from this crazy
lunatic herself Laura Loomer again she's
a former here's how she puts it former
project Veritas operative woo that just
stinks of of Nazi
um so
you see the in the background you
pointed out books a million uh this is a
book signing now this is what the media
the media is like oh Ron DeSantis he's
gonna announce he's running he's running
for there's no way he's not running for
break he's doing a book tour crying out
loud everyone does book tour runs for
president United States listen he
planned this book tour months ago
thinking that Donald Trump would be out
of his way before Donald Trump jumped
all over his announcement right here
eight months ago well whenever Donald
Trump announced it feels like six years
um well or a decade whichever but he
announced decades ago that he was going
to run this year
um but yeah
Ron DeSantis meatball is at this book
some meatball I mean books a million and
he's doing a signing now this guy here
this guy right here with the badge he's
a rent a cop he's not actually a cop
yeah when I first watched this I thought
he was a cop but he's just he just yeah
well you know he's got one of the
Herschel Walker badges so he's funny bro
all right he's a cop he's a he's he
works for the FBI he went to Quantico
right maybe no probably most likely yeah
I mean look at his sunglasses though I
mean this guy reminds me of the
Terminator this guy's badass I
would be back and he literally in
another video he kind of says that I'll
be back
um for those goddamn Trump signs right
now uh to give you context here again
this is a book signing outside of books
of meatball and um this security guard
who is hired as security for Ron
DeSantis and this event
um is approaching Trump supporters now
you would think changes you would
believe
that if Ronda Santos is going to run on
the Republican ticket that he would have
to court Trump supporters wouldn't you
think that that is a possibility I mean
it's a possibility but right I mean
you know you think he could do it
without the Trump supporters
I mean we watched the video yesterday
remember the video yesterday yeah when
the lady had the Rhonda Santos I mean he
would find kill me he was trying to run
around finding someone that say they
both and she had a Santa's shirt on
she's like I might vote for him and
maybe but I also I also Imagine you know
like yes he he does probably need to
court those votes I don't know how many
there are but he does need to court
those votes but also there's a part of
me that's like maybe Ron DeSantis you
know the meatball that fell off the the
plate and down the hill you know how
that story goes like I lost my poor me
ball anyway
oh my God I I have to imagine that these
Republicans have a very short attention
span and we know that they do right they
they happen to selectively have uh
Amnesia they're like they're like flies
on a turd or a trip yeah you know
they're like you know goldfish right
goldfish have like three second memory
spans or something like that I don't
know if that's true or not I heard that
years ago maybe it's not it could be
totally debunked totally disinformation
yeah it still wants to correct me on
that one this just me remembering as a
kid anyway you know I have to imagine
these Trump uh these trumpers these
Republicans these Maga supporters all
have short attention spans so that right
now they might be like super upset that
they were you know they were banned from
being
um yes I'll cover with cheese
um they have been banned from this books
a million okay here are two things one
very surprised that these people even
wanted to go into that place wow
I will say the reason why is because
it's Laura Loomer and what she's trying
to do is she is simping for Trump here
she's simply for Trump if you remember
like her campaign she didn't have Laura
Loomer sure she had Trump shirts yeah
like she was running her campaign like
Trump like what you're running though
um so here it is and she's in this this
is her recording this video now there's
another video out there from another
perspective where she's in the video
because all these people are recording
of course because they think that's we
got you and they're hoping yeah they're
hoping which the funniest part about
this whole thing
is Laura Loomer is trying to make sure
that Rhonda santis does not run against
Donald Trump yeah and what she's trying
to do and she successfully pulled off
the stunt because it is a stunt and Let
Me Tell You Folks you need to start
spreading this around everywhere that
Rhonda Santos is Banning Trump
supporters from his events you need to
spread it around everywhere everywhere
you can now this morning uh Grandpa
Poopypants is attacking Ron DeSantis now
he's also attacking Rupert Murdoch which
oh baby I am here for but
in this in this situation here
um you're going to see this security
guard who is hired by DeSantis and this
book's a million to police this event to
make sure anyone with Trump merch cannot
get in the event they don't even want
people wearing Trump shirts or hats now
maybe underwear because you couldn't see
them but the hats and the shirts and the
capes
and the clown costumes have to go let's
listen are you acting like the far left
we're acting like the far left trying to
get Trump elected yeah well you're
acting like the far left
trying to get Trump elected is the far
left yes trying to get Trump elected is
the far left
I am a trump supporter oh baby
oh baby you listen I I'm gonna show the
rest of this video and I want to show
other Clips if I can find them but this
is the most delicious you're gonna
see all my day and this is the
video literally if you're gonna lift a
video and you're gonna spread it around
this is the video to show Mega
supporters there's the video to show
Ronda Santos supporters you want them to
be fighting in Threads you want them to
be pissed off at each other and going at
each other's throats a trump supporter
who a trump supporter a self-proclaimed
blue lives matter I hate black people
Rhonda Santos meatball security guard
Trump loving guy is telling Laura Loomer
and the Trump supporters who are who are
who are holding their Flags high that
they love Trump that they're acting like
the far left listen to me when I tell
you folks
there is nothing better in our politics
than to spread this narrative they are
so they don't even know it yet
but they are so when they start
calling each other us holy that I
mean you talk you talk about done
turkey done on Thanksgiving burnt in the
oven done that's how done this is let's
let's continue because this it only gets
sweeter and more delicious it's like
technically technically you shouldn't be
over there then I'm doing my job and so
are we so are we but so are we private
property you need to leave okay okay
done that anybody who's wearing a trump
hat shirt anything anything Trump they
have to leave so we're you know Governor
DeSantis likes to pretend like he's a
governor in favor of free speech right
they talk you talk to Big talk but
really he allows for elections to be
stolen by big Tech and now he allows for
people to be you know have the cops
called on them for simply supporting
president Trump we're not we're not the
radical left we're not violent we're
simply supporting president Trump
[Music]
android.com
okay well oh oh my God
I like how she says we're not violent
like we don't do that uh
let's listen when when when these
right-wing idiots of fat the Florida
fascist meatball Rhonda Santos
gets gets their rhetoric turned on them
do you know how they're going to get
defeated in this country you know how
Maga is going to get defeated in this
country by themselves oh my God they're
gonna eat their own sandwich and
they're gonna love every single
bite of this sandwich it is
delicious it is great you should promote
it you should push it you should you
should spread this message around in
every thread that you possibly can find
on social media you know how you get all
these my controls up in your
you know what I mean yeah you
should go getting their with this
oh my God which who whose side are you
on are you on meatball said are you on
are you on Trump's side this is
beautiful uh I want to show you another
uh clip that is um absolutely beautiful
here
um
and a lot of people are questioning and
they question today if Joe Biden Freeze
Frame that's I got the best ones man I
don't and some of them aren't even
intentional they're really none of them
are they're just wear it wear Twitter
it's Elon Musk man he just decides where
it goes
that's pretty good that's a pretty good
Freeze Frame right the right would love
this right I love this flavor it looks
like you know what this look it looks
like Joe Biden uh you know when you hit
your shin on the stairs yeah it's a bit
that's that is the look
yeah yeah
or when you get your funny bone it ain't
so hard and then you know and then
naturally you're like I gotta I gotta
rub the shin and you're like why would I
you know it's that weird thing where
like you have to apply pressure to the
thing or or more pain to the thing that
hurts right now to like get your mind
off it right oh man too many times as a
kid I did that running up the stairs
slipping on my stocks in my socks
hitting my shin on the on the stair like
right on the Edge and I'm like
I was surprised yeah that's the face you
know right before the tears come this is
the face that it's like it's the silent
cry you know when a kid's like
right for you yo mommy mommy oh let's
listen to Joe Biden here he stuffs them
in a trash can though this is this is
great this is great I I can't believe
anyone thinks that someone's gonna run
against this game Let's listen I I've
been around for a lot of state of the
unions
I never saw one where the president got
to negotiate in the open with everybody
I was pleased to see so many Republicans
stand up remember when Marjorie telegram
was yelling Liar Liar finds a liar
if if you're a Catholic out there that
is why me and Gage Sanchez are laughing
because we were raised Catholic
when you're doing the sign of the cross
oh baby too many times my my
grandparents was like oh
they get out their rosary and
you start start doing the rosary oh my
God here look he's not done yet this is
great be good
I'm gonna be good
we don't want to cut anything I so when
I asked I said okay you don't want to
kind of everybody who says we're not
going to cut Medicare Social Security
when I asked them to join us and reject
the cuts Medicare wasn't it something
they all stood up
all stood up
and they're all on camera
Joe Joe Biden has a tendency he's like
and then I'm gonna whisper into the
microphone he does that a lot but it is
funny when he's like
and I did that right it's that's dark
Brandon doc yeah he does that I think
that's throw some smooth jazz on
there and some candle lit area you know
and he's like
oh yeah I did that they totally
they stood for me that was me
baby
um so I've got some March because Marge
is our headliner today
um but I got a couple other videos so
we're gonna try to March through these
let's do the Ted Cruz one we're gonna
Marge through them Marge through them
March through them right speaking of
March yeah uh we got we got first we got
it's March 1st it's March first it's
March 1st happy March everyone
uh we got we got March Madness coming up
AKA bonehead Madness
yeah we can't call it Marge We can't
call it March Madness we want Marge
Marge if we wanted but again she didn't
win last well we don't we don't really
know if we can call it that we can try
it they make Mars Madness right they're
serious about they're serious about it
yeah but it's Marge right I know but
they may I mean we can try and see if
they'll come after us wouldn't that be
fun to get sued by the NCAA that would
be awesome I would love to get a
seasoned assist from the NCAA two guys
on a podcast get sued by the NCAA
because they're calling it Marge Madness
they're like it's too similar in how it
sounds people keep thinking they're
saying Marsh but they're saying Marge
that just brings more attention to it
that could that could be a strategy I'm
just saying and also but also March 15th
you know if people you know remember the
Ides of Marge you know yeah they wear
the Ides of Marge
I'll be tweeting that probably I have
that in my drafts I'm good good well
speaking speaking of uh people who need
cease and desist
um here is here is someone who pretends
he's an attorney you know he used to be
a solicitor for the State of Texas Ted
Cruz yeah you know he fought those
dildos real hard I mean right uh you
know
wait he fought dildos yeah he bought you
to own dildos he didn't he didn't
actually fight the dildos did he uh he
thought he fought an army of dildos
he fought his way through the dildos
dildo Warrior yeah kind of like he had
like a dil like a dildo scapular you
know like an Excalibur type thing where
he was like trying to fight off the
dildos with his big dildo you know oh
okay you know it's just so it's like the
fire with fire you fight dildos yeah
yeah I mean like how are you gonna you
know if this was uh if this was antifa
you know you've got a as it's described
by by um by certain people uh who are
affiliated with the proud boys
um it's called a rubber Rod you know AKA
it's a dildo right you can either get a
cement milkshake which was not true or a
rubber Rod which is talking about handle
now yeah I didn't want to say his name
out loud but sure we'll call him out now
Andy do you know if you say his name
three times does he appear or something
um yeah kind of like Beetlejuice yeah he
basically he shows up and he's got the
the cement milkshake that he made up
right that he said someone threw at him
he has that on him and then he's got a
just a dildo stuff okay like one
of the suction cup ones that you put in
the show no no it's not that I know
anything about those no it's not even
the suction cup it's just like someone
stuck because of the cement okay gotcha
well speaking of uh Beetlejuice and
dildos here's Ted Cruz
um and he is yelling at Merrick Garland
and he's asking Merrick Garland a
question and the Merit Garland says I'll
answer your question and taker says no
you won't I'm serious he asked him a
question and then he says no you're not
can answer the question it's
weird stuff it almost feels like to me
that he's trying to get on Fox News here
it almost feels like Tucker has been
ignoring him and having Marjorie Taylor
green on for saying really stupid
and committee hearings so he's gonna say
really stupid to get back on White
Privilege tonight with Tucker Carlson
let's listen even one Senator you asked
me whether I sat on my hands and quite
the opposite I sent 70 United States
Marshals try again has the Department of
Justice brought even a single case under
the statute so yes no question it's not
a give a speech on the other things you
did the job of the United States
Marshals is to defend the lives so the
answer is no is to defend the lives of
the justices and that's their number one
priority they have why are you unwilling
to say no the answer is no because it's
not no Ted Cruz the answer is not no
damn dude he's having such a
little like tantrum I know the answer is
no yes
okay so um wish.com fat wolverine here
um what he's talking about is when
people went and protested they protested
in front of the Justice's house
um after they they abolish Roe v Wade
taken away rights from other humans in
this country taking away Liberty from
people in this country and he's upset
that people went and protest now what
mayor Garland is saying here is I sent
U.S Marshals to the scene
of the protest and those Marshals had
the authority to arrest those people
they were breaking along they did not
arrest them okay the marshals didn't
arrest them and Ted Cruz is really
pissed off that Merrick Garland didn't
charge peaceful protesters for crimes
they didn't commit because even the U.S
Marshals agreed on the ground that they
weren't committing crimes they were just
there protesting which is not
illegal it's not illegal to protest it's
not illegal to be allowed on public
property and depending on the time of
day and the ordinances but the U.S
Marshals decided not to arrest watch
this exchange and again he's just doing
this for to get on Tucker Carlson's show
but watch you know it's no I know it's
no everyone in this in this hearing room
knows it's no you're not willing to
answer a question have you brought a
case under this statute yes or no as far
as I know we haven't and what we have
done is defended to the lies of the
justices
how do you decide which criminal
statutes the the doj enforces and which
one it doesn't the United States
Marshals know that they have full I
recognize you want to give a separate
speech how do you decide which
issue enforce and which ones you don't
but Marshall's on scene make that
determination in light of the priority
the marshals do not make a determination
over whether the prosecute you the
attorney general make a determination
and you spent 20 years as a judge and
you're perfectly content with justices
being afraid for their children's lives
and you did nothing to prosecute it
let's shift can I answer the question
yeah no I I don't want you to answer the
question because it's a really dumb
question because what Ted Cruz is
surmising here and he knows better is
that a United States Marshal on the
ground is the evidence when they would
arrest someone is the evidence that you
would use to prosecute someone
that is who would collect the evidence
on the ground for the Department of
Justice and a United States Attorney to
prosecute those people on the ground and
what mayor Garland is trying to tell is
bonehead is that the U.S
Marshals had no evidence that a crime
was committed you idiot how the
do you want me to prosecute a
non-crime it doesn't exist and he's not
listening the reason why Ted Cruz isn't
hearing an answer that he wants to hear
is because he is a piece of
garbage wouldn't you agree yeah I will
not he's not just like a one single like
like he's a whole trash can because
remember you know I feel like it Bears
repeating the guy
Senator Ted Cruz abandoned his
constituents and the people of Texas
during the snowpocalypse that was in
Texas in 2021 abandoned them went to
Cancun got busted because people took
photos of him in the airport and on the
plane then he said oh no no no no no I
was just flying my daughters down to
Cancun a job that his wife could totally
have done and while all that was
happening he left his dog's snowflake
ironically named of course at the house
all alone sitting patiently waiting at
the door like a helpless dog because the
owner Ted Cruz
left it like all of the other Texans the
guy doesn't care about people the guy
doesn't care about his family he throws
his daughters under the bus his family
doesn't even like him his his neighbors
don't even like him the guy lives in a
gated community talks about how the
elitists and these East Coast ivy league
where do you go to school where'd he go
to school went to Harvard he
went to Harvard yeah don't don't
even listen to this stain of a rep
of a of a senator
from Texas he's got his little you know
he's got a little cowboy boots
and he's got a little flag on the back
that says uh what is it come and take it
or something like that come come when it
says come and he says come it's the it's
the what's the El Paso no not El Paso
it's the it's the flag with the cannon
and it's the ah hey man hold on
uh uh okay well I thought it might have
said ass no it says come and
take it it's from uh
it's a slogan then all this shitty words
the Battle of uh Thermopylae no okay no
wait hold on hold on hold on
oh it's from the Gonzalez flag story
behind Texas world famous come and take
it flag it's a that he wears when
he's got the mask on you know yeah yeah
it's from Gonzalez he's an idiot he's an
idiot yeah you know who else is an idiot
I've got a I got everyone's a republican
I got his I got a picture of his brand
new plane can you pull up um uh
ass 45s um
uh is fraud Social account real quick I
want to look at it yeah
um Wildlife well I I got a picture this
is just in
um he's landed on the ground in uh
snowflakeville ass one has
landed
um so we're gonna go and look at some of
these
frauds fraud social accounts um post now
I we don't well we probably read what
maybe one a week yeah yeah he actually I
just saw that he reshared the video that
we played yesterday of the people at the
diner
really
oh that's hilarious I love it I love it
it's almost like it's almost it's almost
like yeah here it is so let me let me
pull this up here I don't want you to
use the cookies you
on true social God damn it okay so here
is he he's posting here and he doesn't
say anything this is without comment um
the conservative tree house as you
posted this on I guess they post this on
true social I guess I don't know no no
no no last the rest the last Refuge oh I
bet you can really trust them for sure
oh yeah but this is hilarious since Fox
News having trouble finding Santa
sporters in Florida for the 2024
presidential run and of course you know
it's the video yeah it's the screenshot
of the woman that with the the Santa's
shirt on when she's like meh probably
not yeah probably not gonna vote for
DeSantis because my family will shoot
and kill me they're all domestic terrors
they're all domestic terrorists and they
all voted three times right look at his
ad for the DMV what does it say Missouri
oh it's Missouri launches new policy for
cars used less than 50 miles per day
wow okay Tony you should get that I
should okay so here's the one here's the
uh here's the one um I'm interested in
he's attacking Rupert Murdoch this was
an hour ago or just over an hour ago
this is fantastic folks and he had
another one where he attacked Rupert
Murdoch maybe I should he did but he
spelled stolen with two L's didn't he
today this is the one he spoke spelled
yeah I saw it trending this morning he
reposted yeah yeah yeah yeah so right
here right here it says um but it's not
it's not this is not the first time he
has misspelled stolen there's another
post that people were sharing around I
don't I don't like when people make fun
of people misspelling I don't know if
you've seen my tweets but a lot of
is missing are you kidding me I'm gonna
make fun of Republicans
we're gonna have to play the clip of uh
of Raskin oh I'm gonna play they're
asking yeah okay I'm also I'm hoping to
get to it and the Marjorie Taylor green
Clips
um grandpa says here if Rupert Murdoch
honestly how old this Rupert Murdoch can
you look that up for me who's older
Donald
or Rupert
Murdoch damn God damn is he in his 90s
yet yeah dude he's 91. are you
me yeah he's 91 man oh my God
it really is true the Good Die Young and
the just live for ever
well the reason being that the rich
people or the people who have acted the
only reason that Trump's able to live
long as he has been is because the
health care that he's been given which
is like top dollar that he
doesn't have to pay for we pay for it
right but Rupert Murdoch you know rich
man that's why it's why the rich you
know they're able to live long is
because they have access to incredible
Health Care can we contact the grin
Reaper is do we got a 1-800 number or no
there's a grim reaper oh that's why is
the green is the Grim Reaper man uh so
Grandpa Poopypants is going after uh I
gotta get I gotta get a good nickname
for the Rupert Murdoch
um he honestly believes that the
presidential election of 2020 despite
massive I I'm just reading it how it's
written folks massive amounts of proof
to the contrary
was now rigged and stolen
formerly stole Stalin Stalin I think if
you pronounce it Stalin isn't that a
pastry or some s-t-o-l-l-e-n
it's a pastry or some it's like a
German bread or something uh S no no
s-t-o-l-l-e-n is that what you said yeah
okay yeah authentic it's a German
Christmas bread oh okay so it is but
it's got like a white powder on the
outside and it's gonna look like little
it very very appropriate that Donald
Trump almond paid confused is with a a
German bread with white powder
um and called Stalin um then he and his
group of manga hating globalist rhinos
oh my God
you don't know how happy these phrases
make me do you have any idea how happy
the words coming out of Donald Trump's
mouths pointed towards Fox News Rupert
Murdoch and his allies of manga hating
globalist rhinos is oh my God my thank
you Donald so much you have no clue
what's coming for you in 2024.
um should get out of the news business
as soon as possible
he thinks he thinks this post is gonna
make Rupert go oh my God I think he's
right I should I should just sell my
entire Empire and not be in the fake
news business like Rupert murrach has
been in the fake news business for uh
like two centuries he's like 967 years
old I mean look he was around he started
the propaganda around you know things
that Jesus did when he was around oh
really yeah he was the one he was like
dude we should make a Bible and then we
should sell that Bible and they're like
I'm pretty sure that Christ wouldn't
like that he goes Christ I sold him
out I'm Rupert Murdoch and I'm paying
for the book because of this is this
like I got the 30 pieces of silver that
the Romans gave me and I'm
starting a printing press and I'm gonna
start the Bible and that is how the
Bible came out today did Rupert Murdoch
invent the printing press yeah he did
yeah yeah I know yeah no no no yeah yeah
yeah I'm telling you right now not only
that but he also was the one who he he
started he's like oh books yeah we
should do books we make money on it
people don't read that but you can
yell at people about it ah I see I see
oh well you go you come here to get
your facts at the time you don't have to
fact check me out yeah look it up look
it up tell me I mean like you can you
can try and fact check me okay but I'm
gonna tell you right now that it wasn't
Gutenberg that started the printing
press okay it was Rupert Murdoch I don't
know Mighty librarian Mighty librarian
makes a good point here and she is a
librarian so uh okay she's sourcing
sourcing she's probably sourcing I've
heard I've heard that rumor I have to do
my own fact checking I'll text George
Santos later today uh see if he did he
hasn't you know what speaking of George
Santos I did text him the other day I
said hey
representative Santos God it really hurt
to say that I said hey representative
Santos uh my team or our team
fact checked your recent interview with
Pierce Morgan and we found many
discrepancies with the stories that you
told from over the years did you send
him a link too today what was that video
good uh did he respond at all nope none
at all
I bet he watched it dude it got
delivered so I know that he didn't block
me I can probably text him again right
now and be like so
Gabe is stretching the truth when he
says Rupert Murdoch invented books and
the person
in the truth that he actually did text
George I actually did text George
Sanchez I'll probably make a video about
it yeah um so mighty librarian she's
probably got some Source material here
but she says that George Santos invented
the printing press so we'll get on that
uh I'll have our uh our OnStaff back
Checkers check that um just to be
sure uh okay let's back to the uh the
dribble here from Grandpa
um 80 because they are aiding and
abetting the destruction of America with
fake news he is calling Rupert Murdoch
and Fox News fake news now folks he's
finally come around to the truth he he
actually said something was true
they are they are Rupert Murdock Fox and
these are aiding and abetting the
destruction of America with fake news
he's finally caught on Gabe Sanchez did
you know that in this statement he was
telling the truth
that's a that's amazing I'm not kidding
you I mean here's the thing he tells a
lot of
truths on true social especially when
he's admitting to crimes that he has
committed uh dude I made two perfectly
good phone calls way way
you're talking about two calls you made
a second call right yeah oh but
he's saying Fox News and Rupert Murdoch
the Cheeto dust q and honor is admitting
that they're aiding and abetting the
destruction of America with fake news
I'm glad he's finally come around I'm
glad he finally came around he says
certain Brave and patriotic I'm I'm just
trying to read it the way it's written
Fox News host
who he scorns and ridicules got it right
he got it wrong they should be admired
and praised not rebuked and forsaken
I'm just I'm just reading how you've
screamed it here on true social so so so
it Rupert Murdoch is at fault for
telling the truth
about the lies that they were spreading
knowingly to their about dominion and
the voting machines and 2 000 mules
because if you go down if we go down in
this hell hole of a feed
oh nope not that one now let's see
there's gonna be another one not
that that that's a too oh there's
there he's attacking Paul Ryan
we showed you that video yesterday do
you notice you know Escape Sanchez that
his entire feed
is wedge issuing everything we tell our
audience to wedge issue did you notice
that do you know do you know
you know on point
pontary and
is oh my God I can't tell you it's
almost like it's almost like I've been
saying that this is gonna happen Okay uh
that that here he's attacking him here
here he's attacking Rupert Murdoch with
Judicial Watch which by the way if
anyone's not going to trust the legal
opinion to someone Judicial Watch
Judicial Watch is the one you do
not trust the legal and if anyone
doesn't know who Judicial Watch that's
Tom Fenton okay Tom Finn is the guy that
emailed the white house before the
election happened and said you guys
should declare early and I quote there
was an election and I won and that was
the quote that he told them to say
beforehand just to go out right and say
that's the best legal advice that a
non-lawyer like exactly because tofin is
not a lawyer the guy wears three size
shirts too small is bulging out and he's
like look I'm a guy who knows in love
but isn't a lawyer and I love
sucking Trump's dick do you think he
Tans his balls
I think he totally chance his balls I
think he 100 yeah I think I think you
know what I think he watched Tucker
Carlson yeah he watched that program he
saw how Getty Tucker Carlson got over
men ball tanning and he said I gotta do
that myself oh this is fantastic now he
Tans his balls I'm coming across all
kinds of things all kinds all kinds of
treasure this is a sponsored
ad for a trump hat
yeah because the guy who's gonna go in
camo is going to all of a sudden say hey
you know what I needed to do I need to
add some red some white and some blue to
my hat so the people that are trying to
kill me in whatever uh Zone
military zone I'm in can now identify
and go oh that's not normal why is there
a royal blue in red
out in the wild nope yep cool I know
where my target is you idiot
here's another uh great article that he
is uh
re-frauding here it's from the hill I
don't know if you know about the hill
but the hill is kind of the opposite of
the ginger wash of the hill is not a a
conservative or Nazi rag it is actually
a liberal Rag and he loves this article
in this liberate he loves the liberal
media when they say things like Trump
easily beats DeSantis in a in a GOP
Primary poll which he does in the poll
which we know polls are but that's
that's and here he reposted again from
Breitbart 30-point lead because he's got
a 30-point lead in this pole uh
against DeSantis which I don't need a
poll to tell me here's here it is here's
the here's the pull but I don't need
polls to tell me what I already know
which Donald Trump would
eviscerate
did I miss the rigged one God
damn it I'm there I thought that was I
thought the rig one I'm trying to find
the one where he yells and screams
rigged at the end rigged
I don't know how long ago that was I'm
looking I'm looking oh oh I got it I got
it I got it yeah yeah it's from
yesterday I got it here okay yeah I I'm
looking for that one because I'm rigged
someone said I think oh here it is I got
it I'm way ahead of you I already sent
it to you man I said it before you found
it yeah
Eddie with dead okay so uh
here's another attack he has on Rupert
Murdoch this was yesterday he says why
is Rupert Murdoch
throwing his anchors under the table
it's the bus but you know I don't know
what happened under the table but right
that's not an expression
Grandpa and it's the bus Grandpa that's
not an expression that shut up shut up
kids shut up Aiden and Ricky
get under there just do it what why why
does he think he threw the anchors under
the table and not I don't know
Joe Biden throws people under the table
I don't know what is he talking about I
don't know it seems like a really bad
start to a joke uh why did Don why did
Rupert Murdoch throw his anchors under
the table like that seems like a really
starting he's like why did the chicken
cross the road right exactly why did
Rupert Murdoch throw his anchors under
the table and then I'm sure there's some
dumb pun that follows I mean I mean you
know you can make fun of him for for
misspelling stolen but I think this is
way more marketable right he doesn't
even know it's under the bus the saying
hey it's like uh in Back to the Future
when Biff says you can make like a tree
and get out of here like it's it's it's
not it's not wait you're telling me
that's not the way no that is not the
way damn it I said so he thinks you
throw things under the table not the bus
but you know I have who am I to judge he
says which I want you to judge I don't
know I don't judge a out of him
all day every day that's what we do here
for two full hours uh he goes on to say
which also what happens to be killing
his case and infuriating his viewers who
will again be leaving in droves they
already are listen he's got a contract
with cable companies he doesn't give a
about the viewership he gets a part
of subscription the entire
percentage of the not only that
but the people but the people who
actually go to the fox digital right
which is like the the Box Nation and I
think is what they have yeah yeah Fox 8
which is like exclusive stuff you
wouldn't find it on cable you have to go
and be a subscriber of them specifically
and then you can unlock access a lot of
it I think it's like through the app and
on the website and stuff
but yeah it's dude he doesn't
care also the guy's 91 he's not
gonna go to jail right okay even if he
gets even if he even if Murdoch was
somehow charged with something that
would be like all right you're going to
jail too the guy's 91. I'd be 92
he'll die in jail it's one of those like
you know what we'll just and this is the
unfortunate you know reality of this if
Rupert Murdoch was ever charged and had
to go to jail for whatever
he would have to serve the rest of his
time in his billionaire Mansion
home right and he would still run a box
news because he was like oh I'm about to
die and he would fake that he's dying so
yeah you're home in a hospital but no
they did put away Harvey Weinstein for
an additional 16 or 20 years or whatever
so he's definitely dying in prison
California
uh yeah because it's not only in New
York they got it right right that's
where my man said so they they actually
sentenced him so he's yeah he's gonna
die in prison and deservedly so he's a
bag right him uh let's see
back to uh Grandpa here and his great
story then he has there is massive
evidence of voter fraud and you Larry
there is actually there is massive
evidence for voter fraud and they all
voted for Trump yeah they all voted for
Trump everyone every time you find
there's voter fraud or regulations it's
because that person voted for Trump more
than once right and dead people did vote
yeah they voted for Trump you kill your
wife and your mother-in-law and you vote
for Trump for that right in Pennsylvania
apparently that's what you do uh your
Regulators in the 2020 presidential
election just look at the documentary 2
000 meals oh baby he's invoking 2 000
meals again and you will see a large
scale by the way the 2000 mules movie
the Attorney General former Attorney
General billboard that scumbag under
oath said that the 2000 mules movie is
all horseshit well I think he said
but he said about a
couple things but he also laughed he
laughed at uh
at 2 000 mules in the idea because he
broke down he's like look we looked at
this like cell phone data and we looked
at where the claims were coming and we
looked at the video footage and there
was no
uh there was no fraud these people
weren't weren't harvesting and dropping
them off or anything like that it's
you're watching video and calling it
something that it's not because he goes
on to say that same thing here and you
will see large-scale ballot stuffing
caught on government cameras
and votes cast without legislators
approved or just recently the FBI
Twitter file scandal
[Applause]
oh my God this fool this is
great this is great I've been telling
the audience that this is exactly what
needs to happen and I don't know
um if you understand how fantastic this
is for 2024 but the the idea that
democracy will stand uh only falls on
their their fake ass foundation
uh if we love it so these lies and this
nonsense and this people see
through this they can know the truth a
lot of them won't and that's why
DeSantis won't get in is because they
will continue to be delusional to
Grandpa's little cute story here little
cute story here about how Rupert Murdoch
is ruining Fox News because it's not
praising and worshiping him
I do want to make a a little uh Point
here uh I saw I saw I don't have the
message I saw Rosebud
um
made a comment about how it was
uh I found it here we go yeah yeah so
yeah the and I want to expand on this
it's not a criminal case it's civil no
jail time what I was saying was are you
talking about Fox News yeah yeah yeah
okay what I was saying was if Rupert
Murdoch ever went to jail for any like
not this but if he ever went to jail
just in general
that was my comment to say like he would
never be able to go to jail based on his
age and he would serve out the remainder
of his sentence in in home at home and I
I want to be clear here too because I
said this the other day about facts
you've got 15 minutes we got to get to
these margins yeah yeah apes and the
bobert and the gym are asking Jesus
Christ but I just want to thank Rosebud
for yes but I want to say one thing
expanding on that is that um what Fox
News is doing as much as you want it to
be Criminal
it ain't yeah it ain't crazy it's it's
it's despicable it's terrible
but you ain't gonna lock away any of
these people and you ain't gonna take
them off TV either it's just not gonna
happen it's wishful thinking we have to
be louder than them and we have to have
our arguments projected much on a much
larger scale to drown them out speaking
of people that should be drowned out
this is Marjorie Taylor green sitting on
a a a caucus of voter Integrity I'm not
sure why yesterday this is all footage
all of the clips that we're about to
show she has the same outfit which means
she saw yesterday she went from
committee to committee to committee from
stupid to stupidness herself every way
every possible it's incredible and she
just in one day in one day she still
don't math let's watch a bit of this now
the guy sitting next to her here at the
gray hair
um if you remember back in 2020 when um
they were trying to get he made two
perfect phone calls two perfect criminal
phone calls to the Secretary of State of
Georgia
um this guy was his second in charge and
this guy came out at one point gave a
press conference and basically told the
president to shut his mouth
because people are going to get killed
is basically what it is Gabriel right
Gabriel Sterling is his name
um and and Marjorie Taylor green is
sitting next to him here watch as he
drinks a Coke oh it's it's fantastic
watches thank you very much
you're not going to be able to hear it
very well because of the microphones
show that's
that's not goddammit she's saying
something stupid again well watch this
watch as she starts to speak and she
says I do not consider you an expert on
this matter which he is the expert on
this matter he was the one overseeing
the election so he would know
the the thing that you're wanting to
know but watch as he drinks a coat now
remember this guy is from Georgia and I
don't know if you know how important
Coca-Cola is in Georgia yeah very
important big time so launch watch this
you very much for your executive
expertise on this issue Gabe I do not
consider you an expert on this issue as
a matter of I consider you a major
problem even even is empty it's empty
Gabe Sanchez he's like I finished this
thing 20 minutes ago right I got the
warm few drops left of this coach holy
I'm gonna need it I'm gonna need it
oh my God that's hilarious uh she goes
on to say all kinds of stupid false
misinformation she spews the same
election denial and big lie it's
ridiculous and and as you pointed out
Gabe Sanchez she had no problem lying
yesterday I'm here Texas Paul points out
here
um because she posted this video okay
yeah of a mother who was testifying
before the committee here about Chinese
fentanyl is what she's claiming she's
she's saying Chinese fentanyl her sons
died of a fentanyl overdose this lady
um says it's not a fentanyl
uh well we're gonna find out here let's
watch the video that's pretty sad if
that happened recently
let's watch yeah it would be really sad
whoever the president was during the
time that they were killed but let's
watch this
should never have happened to you it
should never happen to any family
I love the fake crying by the way the
freight the fake emotion oh yeah oh it's
she should have been
an actor
all right let's let's watch it happens
to families at home where I live it
happens to pretty much everyone we know
and I want to ask you now first I want
to thank you for being brave to come
here and share your grief with our
committee but
Miss kiesling would your sons be alive
today if the if our government would
secure our Southern border
okay so the woman goes on to speak and
I'm not going to play the part with her
in it
um because she goes on to say and the
woman actually to be quite honest her
sons died she's in a I mean I can't
imagine that happening to someone right
and she has all kinds of information
mixed around in her head about Fentanyl
and overdoses and what they are and she
she makes it sound like overdoses are
suicide and it's just not what overdoses
are it's just
um her grief has completely distorted
um what is fact and the fact is and
Texas Paul pointed out FYI her boys died
in 2020.
um when Trump was President so the the
fentanyl that they're claiming came
across the border if it did the fentanyl
that they took did come across the
border it is fentanyl that theoretically
a president would let across the border
than it's president Trump that led
across the border Texas fall goes on to
point out that all Republicans are
worthless trash all of them and I I
can't I can't agree with him anymore
because I'll tell you that margin Taylor
green with this stunt is disgusting but
I'll be honest with you the mom
participating in this stunt oh my God
and here's here's how you know let me
show you look the community notes now
have it corrected that's good right so
Marjorie Taylor Green's tweet is
corrected saying that that these two uh
children of this woman did not die while
Joe Biden was President it was in 2020
When Donald Trump was President so
um you know again I I hope that lady
wasn't also what state what state was
this in
uh you know I'm not really sure I know I
have no idea okay because well this is
does that say Detroit news
I'm trying to think of like where that
happened but also it's like it could be
Detroit because here's the other here's
the argument or here's the other side of
this that you know you'd have to track
back where it came from but Marjorie
Taylor green is saying like oh look this
fennel came across the border and it's
all because of Joe Biden do we know that
it came across the border do we know
that it didn't come from somewhere else
right I mean oh I guess she says China
right but I mean still well she says
Chinese and the reason why she says
Chinese because she's a racist
right I mean it would be fentanyl from
China right but you know but you know
it's a whole like Chinese flu you know
Wuhan flew As Trump like to say okay so
here is Marjorie Taylor Green in this
because you can see it's the same thing
man this is the same Committee
hearing
now she just blamed Joe Biden for the
deaths of the woman's sons who died in
2020 while Trump was President then she
goes on to point out that Joe Biden is
doing a better job at stopping that
fentanyl at the border which would only
indicate that Joe Biden is doing a
better job than Joe Biden but you know I
used to say let's listen Fentanyl
I want you to know that in 2020 there
were 4.8 000 pounds of fentanyl Seas by
CBP okay did you catch that Gabe did you
catch the meganomics did you catch it
yeah I got yeah yeah number four grand
four thousand four point one thousand
got it you got the magnomics you got
your number yeah
is this gonna be a magic trick and just
we're gonna do some math let's okay
but in 2021 fiscal year 2021 it
increased to 11.2
000 pounds of fentanyl okay so you had
2020 okay 4.8 4.8
000. it's not actually but four point
eight thousand that was under President
Who
Trump okay all right good good good job
you know your meganomics now
while Joe Biden is President it it the
the amount of fentanyl that was seized
at the border gave Sanchez was 11 Point
whatever thousand
at the border under President Joe Biden
so yes there more or less fentanyl
stopped at the border this is a
magnomics question okay okay all right
so if Susie gets on a train at 3 P.M yes
and is heading south at 70 miles an hour
correct and Tommy gets on a train
heading north at 4 P.M at 120 miles an
hour yes
how long would it take them to reach the
border to get the fentanyl seized okay
um
so listen to her answer and then maybe
it'll help you with your answer okay
okay okay by the CBP that is a direct
result of Biden Administration failure
policies
I'm not sure direct result of Biden
failure I'm not sure if that's a
sentence and maybe this is the
magonomics thing happening here yeah
yeah but okay she's saying she's saying
that when you seize more of the fentanyl
coming across the border that is a
failure is what I'm seeing that she's
wait does deceased mean that you you let
something go like you let it through no
no no no you st no no no no no no the
seat here's the difference Let me Give
an example okay so if you were gonna if
you were gonna be if you were Chad and
you were cooking and cutting fentanyl on
your down the street right okay and
you go to Mexico to buy fentanyl in your
car right you're an American citizen
you're a white guy you're Chad that's
true okay okay can you go to Mexico to
buy Fentanyl and let's say you had a
really big truck and you put 4 000
pounds in that truck and as you cross
the border back to your house to cook
and cut the fentanyl to sell his drugs
street drugs you would be stopped and
Siege means they would take it from you
like they would oh that's what seized
means yeah
oh okay okay okay wow that's okay that
well I I need to call some people right
um okay all right so the so the bonehead
the magnomics here is the bonehead
thinks that it's a Biden Administration
failure to seize more fentanyl than less
fentanyl that Trump sees I mean it's
it's pretty amazing to understand or not
understand what the word seized means
right to cease to stop to take to
prevent maintain stolen or stolen stolen
whatever you know it but it's it is one
of those things where you you know and I
even said this in a tweet I said it's
2023 and Republicans like Marjorie
Taylor green are still
struggling
with understanding what seized means
well I think this is the clip that
you're talking about here isn't it uh no
this is another one well uh okay
and you said I told you man yesterday
she had a day she said you said
thank you
you
called her
I'm telling you right now I'm the uh
dude called her mathry Taylor green find
someone that is my new nickname for
Margaret Taylor green it is Matthew
Taylor green and uh I have not seen
anyone else use it online and I am the
first one to use it I'm telling you
right now you can time stamp it March
1st 10 55 a.m Pacific time when I
tweeted that yesterday
I was the only person
to give her that name especially
surrounding her superb arithmetic skills
it's meganomics it's meganomics dude
Matthew Taylor green got her
primitive
magnomics degree from Trump University
oh my god so let's play this 26 seconds
of math three Taylor green struggling
what it did to our children's math and
reading levels is horrific uh school oh
wait wait she's going to tell us about
she's going to tell us about what she's
struggling in here okay let's continue
closures brought them to the lowest
levels in years England 8th graders math
proficiency dropped by seven points
reading levels dropped by two points
okay there are one million 524
524 and 481 this is over one million 1.5
million what it did to our children this
is reading levels this is a big number
guys this is a big number
can you go back I just want to watch the
struggle happen again
oh
my God let me just let me just enjoy
lean back in my chair here and said
where is it where is it I can't I think
it's halfway through okay two points
there are one million
524 481 this is over one million 1.5
[Music]
oh man oh
there's people in Georgia who who think
it's a good thing for her to be the
elected representative I mean people
people in Georgia really have to look
back and say oh my god did we make the
right choice and then I'm sure I'm sure
I almost there's a part of me that
thinks that Margie Taylor green would
have should have dropped the number and
said 6 billion 6 billion
one million
565 gazillion
235 460.25
000 what the oh my God oh my God
have you ever watched like um I don't
know a train wreck Yeah well yeah well
what will happen in in Ohio yeah like a
four-year-old you give them a really big
number and they're trying to say the
number four five
six seven
it's really big it's a big number man
it reminds me of Derek Zoolander he's
like the building has to be at least
three times this size and they're like
uh yeah totally okay oh my God this
woman
the it's a I just want to say that clip
alone is a work of art someone who wants
to critique
education
and how how well students are performing
yet cannot read a number
a grade schooler could read it shows
that our education system has been
broken in Georgia for a long time a long
time a Greg points out a really good
Steven here and these are the dumb
running our country and it is the dumb
flexor in our country um you know
there's not only one idiot that knows
her meganomics really well there's
another one that knows megabonics uh-huh
yeah really well two megabonics not to
be confused with mega nomics
um and here Jamie Raskin is pointing it
out on the floor um I think that
congresswoman is Lauren bobert and
there's another clip I'm going to show
you of Jamie Raskin
um stuffing her in a trash can too so
let's watch this one here because I also
wanted to make just a brief semantic
point because the gentlelady was making
a grammatical error that I heard some of
her colleagues make before
um I believe she referred to a Democrat
solution I heard another member talk
about a Democrat member and a Democrat
plan I just wanted to educate or just I
don't think this is going to go well for
the person that he's talking no I just
wanna I just wanna um give the audience
a heads up I don't think this is going
to go well for them let's let's see what
he what he how he corrects them here
distinguished colleagues the Democrat is
the noun when you use it as an adjective
you say the Democratic member or the
Democratic solution or the Democratic
plan and so I assume it's a good faith
grammatical error the the first few
times but after people were corrected
several times and they continue to say
it it seems like it's an act of
incivility as if every time we mentioned
the other party it just came out with a
kind of political speech impediment like
oh the Banana Republican party because
if we were to say that every time we
mentioned the Banana Republican member
or the Banana Republican plan where the
Banana Republican conference but we
wouldn't do that so
I love I love it I love the inner and
he's like I would never call my
colleagues
you know I've heard that before Donald
Trump being like look I'm I'm not
calling Ron DeSantis a meatball right
but there are people calling him
meatball DeSantis and again I'm not the
one calling him that but other people
seem to be calling him meatball DeSantis
right so don't call him whatever you do
don't call him don't call him meatball
yeah and speaking of meatball heads uh
here is game you're asking again
squashing another meatball
watch Lauren bobert make a fool out of
herself and then Jamie ransker pointed
out for the entire world to see it's
beautiful watch
um you're right president Trump was in
office when The coveted virus was
released from a lab in China
yeah
you're right Trump you're right yes
you're right I handled the coveted
response I can almost end it there I
don't even have to show the okay
I'm glad now we admit that he was the
one in charge right the people's lives
at that point oh so even just that clip
just knowing that little bit right that
little sound bite Jamie you're asking I
mean she just set the ball up on the T
here watch this he tried to make that no
what no I was just I just thought of
something whenever you hear Republicans
be like oh Donald Trump did this and did
that you know like
uh uh when it comes to covid right
there's this whole thing of like people
like oh I'm not gonna take the vaccine
I'm not going to wear a mask I don't
even do anything because it's all made
up right and then there's the whole
argument they're like oh Donald Trump
did uh project warp speed right which
that wasn't really his thing and he
actually was not successful in
but when you think of these things
they're admitting they have to they have
to pick one of the lane right he either
did nothing because kovid was not a big
deal and it was all hoax or covid was
something and he did do something to
prevent but even the people who now have
to admit that are part of the
anti-masking anti-vaxx group so it's
it's very funny to see them try to
juggle both to be like well yeah he was
president and so he should get credit or
yeah he was present with covet but kova
wasn't a big thing and all these people
just happened to die for whatever you
know right well I mean if you're looking
for it to make sense you're in trouble
um uh D points out something and he says
meatloaf has no right to criticize
meatball
um the meatloaf meatball or Civil War is
is ongoing and active but let's let's
listen to this meatloaf or meatball
whatever she is here the meat head here
you know she make loose meat sandwiches
that gave people the shits yeah she gave
pork sliders that went right on through
to the toilet right loose so loose meat
bobert here let's listen to how she gets
stuffed in the in a locker by Jamie
ranskin very clear that this came from
China and reporters regularly yeah
dismiss that I appreciate the
gentlelady's passion they're two facts
that she should perhaps be alerted to oh
God one is that Donald Trump on more
than 20 different occasions defended the
performance of the Chinese government
and specifically
um president XI in terms of his
treatment of covid-19 and said he was
doing a wonderful job and a great job
and they were working closely and they
were constantly in touch so if there's a
problem with the Chinese government
unleashing a virus which has not been
proven anywhere but it certainly could
be true you would have to pin that on
your uh favorite President Donald Trump
not on Joe Biden the second thing is
President Trump's own special advisor on
Covenant team Deborah Burks I'm sure
you're aware and you're sure you've read
her book uh said that wait wait wait did
Jamie Raskin just assume that Lauren
bobert read a book I'm I want to be
clear I know this is satire and Jamie
ranskin is very good at it yeah he's
really he's really sending an arrow her
way when he says I'm sure you read her
I'm sure you've read your book you
didn't even write your own book Lauren
bobert
I want to point out too
um because we're running out of time but
Jamie Askin is wearing uh a handkerchief
over his head
um and the reason why is because he's
ongoing receiving treatments for kids
he's going through chemotherapy right
now right he's finishing up the lap like
I think he was on Stephanie rules show
last week and I think what he said was
he was in the last like he's finishing
up chemo I think right now but but I
want to point out
that Jamie Raskin
because of his illness
um could be taking a break right now
yeah he could be he could be making sure
that he's getting enough rest
that he his treatments are working the
way they need to that he's relaxing that
he he if he's at the end of his
treatments that he he fights for another
day but that's not what the guy's doing
the guy's right here he's in the thick
of it and he's making sure that everyone
around the world knows that this
bonehead is definitely 100 percent
a loose meat bonehead so let's listen
how he finishes it up here lethal
recklessness of Donald Trump's policies
about covid-19 cost Americans hundreds
of thousands of lives so you don't have
to believe anybody on the Democratic
side of the aisle that's Donald Trump's
own special advisor on covet 19. thank
you for yielding and I have a yield back
yeah and he happily yields back I want
to point out that also Lauren Berber
does not know how to yield back her time
she never does it correctly the other
day oh no that's that's fine I mean and
it's something you know she doesn't know
proper protocol or procedure in place
but the other thing too is I don't know
if people know this but Stephen Van Sant
is the is the one who gave him his
headbands
uh yeah right uh and if people don't
know obviously you know Bruce
Springsteen's Eastern uh E Street Band
but like the fact that you got that from
from Stephen van zand I think is I think
it's pretty cool right it's look it's
it doesn't carry the same way as like
um
uh you know
uh why am I blank on his name uh Kid
Rock right you know I know it's not as
cool as kid rock or it's not as cool as
uh as uh what's the guy with the gun
you can't scratch fever uh Ted Nugent
yeah Ted Nugent that's right yeah who
yeah who got coveted and blame China and
all that I know it's not cool
those guys okay
you got
to die yeah I know I'm really pissed off
I know especially because he's like
pissed off very eases me off
very xenophobic and races against
Chinese people I want to point out one
thing before we leave here because we
are running out of time
um and minus touch you know we're
affiliated we're on the Midas touch
Facebook say hi everybody
um my such points out this morning this
is massive Eli Lilly just caved to
pressure from President Biden and the
Democrats
and this camping insulin out of pocket
costs 35
or less huge now this is this is big
because a reminder that Republicans work
their asses off to make sure everyone
outside of Medicare and Medicaid and
government spending did not receive this
benefit they worked their asses off to
make sure that people had to pay more uh
for 35 insulin or less they voted
against lowering these costs in the
Senate
to take the that part out of the bill
and only remaining the Medicare and
Medicaid payment
um this is going to change a lot of
lives and it certainly will I mean look
every single talking point that
Republicans have had from the point of
before the 2020 election to through the
midterms to now up until the next
general election
every single talking about gas prices
inflation uh you know our domestic uh
Security International policy uh you
know Health Care insulin all of these
talking points that Republicans want to
blame democrats for not doing anything
or want to blame democrats for being the
cause of right jobs as well like all of
these things every single talking point
Joe Biden in two years
as increased manufacturing has increased
labor job has increased the ability to
you know access and affordability to
health care options uh you know lower
the price to gas through different uh
reserves and also other deals yeah all
kinds of international strategy yeah I
mean the guy you know it's not his first
rodeo dude he was a vice president
before and he was
too long exactly he knows government too
well Gabe Jazz he just knows it forwards
and backwards and that's a bad thing a
horrible thing for the president United
States to know how the government works
trade works when it comes to 2024 it's
going to be very hard to to pick apart
the stuff that he did poorly when you
have a long list of wins that are very
pro-american it feels like
when I say that no one is going to mount
a campaign against you but it almost
feels like I'm gonna be right on that it
just it just I mean there's no way
unless he decides himself right but
again we talked with you know Dr uh
Rachel bidikoffer about this and the
fact that like if you're already halfway
up the Hill right if you're
climbing Mount Everest which is a
two-term process let's say right you're
halfway up and you already have the like
you're not low on supplies your
team's still alive you won by eight
million votes yeah you won by eight
million votes and you're still owning a
guy who's having a tantrum who stole
classified documents and you know that's
gonna be your opponent
he's a loser I mean it's not hard for
people to look at that and say president
Trump did nothing but screw over the
middle class and other work in Americans
during his time and Joe Biden came in
and had to clean that up right well
and and the fact that that someone would
mount a campaign against this record is
absolutely ridiculous
I mean you're you aren't going to get
out of one primary I don't give a
who you are I don't care if you're
Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or
Marianne Williamson I think is um oh
that's a new one right yeah yeah oh yeah
oh my God okay good good luck to you
even Gavin Newsom as much as as as well
as he's done as governor of California
even fending off a recall
um with great with great success by the
way which is not which is very rare in
California recall history yeah by the
way I mean Lori Lightfoot just got she
just she lost her runoff election in
Chicago she ain't going to be president
either yeah listen folks when I tell you
this and I know you're like oh he's old
and blah blah we want someone new and uh
yeah okay great I get it there's always
2028 because it ain't happening in 2024
as long as Joe Biden wants to be the
president United States he's gonna be
and the dude's doing a good job
regardless of if it's not how far you
would go the guy with what he's got and
what he's done has gotten gotten more
for the the American people in the
middle class and the working class then
almost any other modern president if you
want to put him up against I mean
Clinton did a hell of a lot of good
things he did a lot of bad things Obama
did a lot of good things he did a lot of
bad things too but this President of the
United States is going in history is
going to go down as one of the most
effective
hear my words he's gonna go down as one
of the most effective presidents in the
United States in our history modern
history yeah you'll be go down as one of
the most effective presents as well as
Nancy Pelosi as much as you love her
hater will go down as one of the most
effective
speaker of the house and when you're
comparing her to like Paul Ryan and
Kevin McCarthy
Zach just
just shit's turn oh my God we're way out
of time so oh boy but if you're still
here on YouTube go ahead and subscribe
to YouTube it's free and it
costs you a nickel to subscribe to this
channel push the like button share it
and then cost you a thing just a little
bit of time go ahead and follow us at
Tony Michaels pod we're going to be
putting out the bonehead of the week
pole tomorrow because on Friday we have
bone of the week you can also download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast that's free as well you
said the other day free 99 3.99 you know
five finger discount on the Tony
Michaels podcast in the afternoon on
your favorite directory doesn't cost you
a single nickel you're stealing from us
as a matter of fact so
be my guest deal uh steel also uh go to
Facebook if you still have a Facebook
account at the Tony Michaels and follow
us on the upwire.com you just go to
upwire.com go to their YouTube channel
you can follow us there we broadcast
live from that channel as well so you
can watch there you watch here more
everyone watch and also you can go to
Twitch
and you can log in with your Amazon
Prime account and give us your one free
subscription that helps the show as well
Gabe Sanchez yeah I need I'm gonna have
the chant hold you accountable are we
gonna get I want to have these PAB 45
stickers this afternoon yeah can we get
can we I I think here's what we'll do we
we teased it the other day I'm gonna
tease it again this this design it's the
preliminary design but I think we can
finalize this so we can get a sticker
and a coffee mug
in the store today so is everybody ready
in the chat are you ready you're gonna
see it it's gonna be quick there it is
there's the design the pab45 so this
afternoon we'll announce it on Twitter
we'll retweet it and send it out there
I'll put it on patreon by the way
patreon speaking of patreon oh
patreon.com the Tony Michaels check out
there and also check out Gabe Sanchez's
patreon patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
having a lot of extras over there with
what was that check out those pages as
well for support but go to
store.tonymichaels.com you'll find the
pab45 ass
stickers and coffee mugs this afternoon
I'll announce it on social media so
follow us everywhere go to the attorney
michaels.com
and you can follow us everywhere same
time same place tomorrow same exact
place same exact
time
Surf's Up you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon